Ginger armor is the daily moisturizing
mineral sunscreen perfect for any skin
type chemical sunscreens can cause
health issues including skin irritation
and stinging eyes but with ginger armors
ingredients from plants and minerals and
it being scent free and rubbing on
invisibly in seconds it's the best get
15 off with code Pacman using the link
below an anti-semitic attacker yelled
Kanye 2024 while committing the attack
and we are going to talk about what
happened and importantly this is not
about Kanye being legally responsible
for the attack or anything like it this
is about realizing that when
high-profile celebrities like Kanye West
make anti-semitic comments it
contributes to normalizing and accepting
anti-Semitism in society that's the
point that we are making here let's go
to the Washington Post article attacker
yells Kanye 2024 during anti-semitic
assault police say NYPD is investigating
an alleged attack in Central Park this
week in which a man in his mid-40s
assaulted a 63-year-old man and spewed
anti-semitic comments before yelling out
Kanye 2024 of course a reference to
Kanye's anti-semitic rhetoric the older
man was walking in Central Park about 7
30 PM Wednesday
when the other man allegedly hit him
from behind according to police when the
older man fell to the ground he broke
his hand and chipped a tooth the
attacker then uttered numerous
anti-semitic comments towards the man
according to police before the attacker
fled on a bicycle with a trailer
featuring a sign reading hungry disabled
police say he referenced the artist
formerly known as Kanye West who has
issued several anti-semitic tirades
senkanye 2024. 63 year old man has not
been publicly identified anti-semitic
attacks in the U.S are at an all-time
high so when high-profile individuals
make statements or they engage in
behaviors that are perceived as
anti-semitic or that are anti-Semitic it
can give the impression that this type
of bigotry is acceptable and mainstream
and in fact when it comes specifically
to anti-Semitism it's very popular it's
very in Vogue to say we don't even
really need to treat it as seriously as
other isms because Jews are privileged
in 2022. we've talked about that
extensively and we've talked about how
that very refrain is in and of itself
based on anti-semitic tropes and
stereotypes but this is why it's not as
simple as many of the emails I get from
some of you lovely people who say it
doesn't matter that Kanye's anti-semitic
fine maybe he's anti-semitic some people
email me and they say the stuff's Kanye
Kanye is saying is true okay there's
people who recognize yes these are
anti-semitic tropes but it doesn't
matter just Kanye it doesn't matter it's
a vicious circle in fact and that
matters very much the use of
anti-Semitic language or imagery by
celebrities fuels the spread of that
very misinformation and those conspiracy
theories and tropes which then in the
followers of these celebrities creates a
new cycle of emboldening and furthering
and exacerbating those very beliefs
which only creates more of it it's a
vicious circle and we've seen many
examples of this it's not only Kanye I
mean listen we can go back to Henry Ford
if you really want to but without going
back that far Mel Gibson in 2006 Mel
Gibson had this incident where he was
arrested drunk driving and he made a
bunch of anti-Semitic statements to the
officer he said to the guy are you a Jew
crazy but I believe the officer was
Jewish which is just I mean that's
another whole incredible coincidence uh
saying the Jews are responsible for the
wars in the world and all this stuff and
you know he eventually apologized and I
think Mel Gibson's acting again I don't
know but at the time it created a lot of
this Mel Gibson's willing to say stuff a
lot of people in Hollywood aren't
willing to say Louis Farrakhan we've
talked about many times before he's the
leader of the Nation of Islam very long
history of anti-Semitic statements
blamed the Jews for 9 11. uh typical
stuff Jews are actually the ones in
control of the government that type of
thing he has a significant following and
there are lots of folks in the Nation of
Islam who maybe don't come in with
particular views about Jews but there
they end up informed by Louis Farrakhan
and then you have a whole new generation
of people who repeat the same stuff
um an ice cube had an incident rapper
Ice Cube promoted some conspiracy
theories about Jews on social media
claimed Jews are responsible for the
slave trade which isn't true and he
um responded by saying I'm not promoting
anti-Semitism I'm raising questions
about the history of slavery questions
that are very extensively answered by by
history so it's a vicious circle of
stuff
The Vicious Circle itself perpetuates
the belief and then it creates more of a
problem and anti-Semitism like other
forms of bigotry is often based on
negative stereotypes and prejudices
about Jews the prejudices themselves
make it easier for people to believe the
conspiracy theories and even if there's
no evidence to support them it's a
feedback loop it's like if you put a
microphone up to a speaker and then you
know a feedback loop there are also
psychological factors because research
has found that people are more likely to
believe conspiracy theories when they're
feeling anxious or uncertain in a time
of Crisis or change they become more
susceptible to believing this stuff and
we have a right-wing party in the United
States the Republican party that for a
decade now has been based on using fear
and making people afraid that they're
going to lose their way of life or their
lives or whatever and that actually
primes people to be even more likely to
fall for this stuff in the first place
so the full circle of the Kanye
anti-Semitism and we'll follow up on the
story probably on a forthcoming bonus
show this is absolutely fascinating the
right wing Wall Street Journal
part of news corporation owned by Rupert
Murdoch has put out an op-ed
indicating that although Republicans
will be taking control of the house in
just a few weeks they are too dim-witted
essentially too stupid to wield power
this is super interesting not because
someone wrote Republicans are kind of
dim
most of us knew that but because the
right-wing editorial board of the Wall
Street Journal wrote it Republican party
masochists writes the editorial board on
uh Friday Republican Division and
disarray on Capitol Hill bowed ill for
the next Congress and the entire article
is worth reading but there's a
particular article that is interesting
um
I'll actually start with a paragraph
before their main demand is so
self-defeating talking about Republicans
here their main demand is so
self-defeating it could have come from
democratic congresswoman Alexandria
ocasio-cortez the dissenters want Kevin
McCarthy to concede that any member
could call the chair vacant and insist
on a vote to replace the sitting speaker
in order to get the votes to become
speaker McCarthy is supposed to weaken
himself so much that he wouldn't be able
to govern as Speaker yet a narrow
Republican majority of only 222 to 213
requires a leader who can enforce party
discipline that's how Nancy Pelosi has
been able to govern with the mirror
image majority in the last two years too
many House Republicans are too
dim-witted to understand the uses of
power and how to wield it they'd rather
Rage Against the Machine to no useful
effect
I don't care who wrote this and it
happens to be the right wing Wall Street
Journal editorial board
it's completely correct and accurate as
an assessment of the Republican party
right now they are so obsessed with rage
and anger and fear that they care more
about perpetuating oh we're we're gonna
take down McCarthy our Focus will be to
go after Hunter Biden or to impeach Joe
Biden even if we don't know why and
we're going to make people afraid of the
immigrants that Joe Biden's letting in
even though there's really no
significant changes to immigration
policy from Biden since Trump this is
what it's all about the rage is what
many of the modern Mega trumpists used
rage and fear to get elected in the
first place last week we talked about
reactionary populism many of them using
reactionary populism which includes
making people angry and making people
afraid that's why they don't have plans
or policies that's why they are totally
lacking in policy and a policy platform
Beyond just stop the Democrats from
doing uh what they want to do or what
they would like to do they were the
angry opposition to what was happening
in power democrats for a while now
they're going to be in office they're
going to control the House of
Representatives the outrage is all that
they have and so that rage this is the
correct answer we've seen it for so long
now among these people and many of them
and I've spent time in parts of the
country where this is the case they grew
up in a church I spent time in rural
Northern or rural as some like to say I
don't say it that way rural Northern
Indiana and people basically go to two
places they go to church and they go to
a shooting range those are places where
you become angry and you become afraid
you're filled with hate rage and anger
and you see it firsthand in a lot of
these conservative places and they use
fear of immigrants members of the
Republican Party say it the dangerous
immigrants are going to come in you've
got to be afraid of them so we need
nativist immigration policy we certainly
need guns to protect ourselves from them
ignoring the reality
that both
uh naturalized
legal and undocumented immigrants both
are less likely to commit crime in the
United States than natural born citizens
and it makes sense if you know your
status is not legal or you have legal
status but you still see yourself as
someone who came here later you would
probably go out of your way to avoid
criminality and interactions with police
widely documented but yet fear of
immigrants it's in the church
is part of the narrative around why
people need guns grievances over
perceived injustices the right loves to
say it's the left that does grievance
politics actually it's the right it's
the right black lives matter movement is
bad and discriminatory and terrible and
we have a grievance against them and we
must fight them antifa
I could go on and on the the Free Speech
rights that are being taken away from us
which really aren't being taken away and
then of course the use of divisive
rhetoric for its own sake
um protect American values defend the
Constitution
defend and restore Free Speech things
that are meaningless if you follow the
facts on the ground but that they use to
drive these politics so I believe the
Wall Street editorial board is right
these Republicans will be taking control
of the house but they are too dim-witted
to really understand how to wield power
this is a good thing for the left to the
extent that they end up just chasing
their tails talking about Hunter Biden
for two years and hopefully
accomplishing nothing and maybe
Democrats can get a couple of things
done while Republicans are busy trying
to impeach Joe Biden Donald Trump is now
panicking about the increasingly likely
scenario in which his tax returns leak
he spent the overnight on his platform
truth social essential call it whatever
you want uh complaining and telling lies
let's back up just a little bit there's
two things going on simultaneously later
today the January 6 committee is
expected to announce uh which criminal
referrals are they sending to the
Department of Justice Trump may be on
that list we don't yet know that's
number one separately the house Ways and
Means Committee has finally obtained
Donald Trump's tax returns Trump spent
years trying to keep them secret for a
guy with nothing to hide I haven't seen
so much money spent trying to keep those
tax returns secret Trump is now worried
that the tax returns are going to leak
and he clearly is worried
I believe because he thinks that the
subject the content of those tax returns
would be bad for him so he goes on trout
Central last night 10 11 midnight and he
starts quote the highly partisan
unselect committee is illegally leaking
confidential info to anyone that will
listen Adam's Shifty shift is all over
TV talking about Capital C criminal
referrals just like he was on the
russia-russia Russia hoax which turned
out to be the con of the century how
much longer are Republicans and American
Patriots in general going to allow this
to happen these are the capital c
criminals who spied on my campaign
cheated on the capital E election lied
to fisa court in Congress they are sick
Trump then when Trump starts these rants
it's often like okay what's this what's
this about what triggered this his next
post exposes what this is all about
Trump says quote you can't learn much
from tax returns but it is illegal to
release them if they are not yours Trump
worried about his tax returns being
released it's also not true that you
can't learn much from tax returns tax
experts have said you might be able to
glean from tax returns that Trump's not
as wealthy as he claims to be that he
has debts to Shady figures that might
have him compromised that he is engaged
in tax fraud
and a number of other things Trump
continuing quote all of the so-called
experts who think that they know so much
about my very successful private company
actually know almost nothing it is a
great company with lots of cash and some
of the greatest assets anywhere in the
capital W world and very little debt
also strong on deductions and
depreciation you will be seeing these
numbers soon where have we heard that
before from before but not all from my
tax returns which show relatively little
everyone will be impressed but the fake
news media will not be happy so against
their narrative
is anybody still falling for the we're
gonna release the documents very soon
thing I mean that's been going on for
almost eight years at this point
Trump continuing the real criminals are
the people who were destroying our once
great Capital C country and Trump
closing it off election interference by
the FBI and Twitter was massive and
determinative how sad of course that's
not true but when in doubt go back to I
guess what's been working for you which
is claim you really won
more than two years ago
oh boy if the tax returns leak this guy
is going to go cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
and I look forward to it I would never
encourage anyone to commit a crime or
leak anything but if the tax returns
leak it's going to be quite a scene
folks this Friday we are doing something
we have never done before Friday
December 23rd yes we're doing a
membership special it's the last
membership special of the year but
here's the incredible thing we are doing
your first month's payment of this
discounted membership will be donated by
us to a charity that they don't run it
through this huge complex process where
at the end of the day 45 cents on the
dollar get to the people we're trying to
help we are going to be donating the
first months of everybody's memberships
uh this Friday when you use a special
coupon code to a charity that sends cash
to people who need and we're talking
people who really need it people living
on a dollar a day to like two dollars a
day okay in addition the money is going
to be doubled now I can't say exactly
through which charity because if I did
it creates a marketing situation where a
contract it's just complicated so what
we've been told to do is David just
promote it this way and then on Friday
you can announce what you're doing with
the money once you already have it okay
so that it's for legal reasons we're
doing it that way
how do you get notified about all of
this this is unbelievable you will get a
membership at a discount and that
discounted payment will go to people who
need it and be doubled we've never done
something like this before I want it to
be really successful get on my mailing
list at davidpackman.com top right of
the website you'll see a place you can
type in your email you do need to know
your email address for that to work
Friday morning you'll get an email
telling you here's the coupon code
every payment gonna be donated and it
will be doubled it will be matched
dollar for dollar up to the first
fifteen thousand dollars which I think
is going to be more than enough for for
our purposes I'll talk more about it
we'll take a quick break and be back
with much more from the news of the
weekend
one of our sponsors today is ginger
armor the daily moisturizing mineral
sunscreen that's good for you and the
planet I've talked before about why I
only use mineral sunscreen instead of
chemical sunscreen I want a physical
barrier rather than chemicals absorbed
by the skin Ginger armor is an everyday
sunscreen moisturizer lip balm combo
that goes on lightweight unseen and
unscented perfect for all skin types
with powerful SPF 50 plus protection
rubs on invisibly in seconds no smell
feels good after shaving to stay
moisturized all day and the super
portable design is really good on the go
and it's made with 21 simple Earth
friendly ingredients from plants and
minerals unlike the chemical sunscreens
which can irritate skin worsen certain
conditions sting eyes Ginger armor is my
go-to for daily skin protection and
moisturizing even in Winter I know
you'll love it too it's also more
affordable than other mineral sunscreens
and it is a small business supporting
the David Pacman show go to
gingerarmor.com and use code Pacman for
15 off the link is below there is
evidence to criminally charge the failed
former president Donald Trump
says Adam Schiff member of the January
6th committee we have video of Adam
Schiff explaining I've seen the evidence
there is evidence that Donald Trump
committed criminal offenses in his
effort to overturn the 2020 election now
Adam Schiff has previously said things
like we have the evidence that will put
Don Jr in prison or at least get him
charged and it appears as though he was
wrong about that so Adam Schiff is no
Panacea but we are within hours right
now of the January 6 committee making
criminal referrals we don't yet know
who's going to be on that list and you
have Adam Schiff saying the following
let's take a listen and then discuss
what we'll discuss well what could be
those charges uh I think that the
evidence is there that Donald Trump
committed criminal offenses in
connection with his efforts to overturn
the election and viewing it as a former
prosecutor I think there's sufficient
evidence to to charge the president wow
now well I don't know what the justice
department has I do know what's in the
public record the evidence seems pretty
plain to me but I would want to see the
full body of evidence if I were in the
prosecutor's shoes to make a decision
but uh you know this is someone who uh
in multiple ways tried to pressure State
officials to find votes that didn't
exist this is someone who tried to
interfere with a joint session uh even
inciting a mob to attack the capital
true
um if that's not criminal then uh
now I know what it is so let's take this
seriously and think it through let's not
speak in general terms about this
according to the investigation by the
January 6 committee there's evidence
that Trump committed crimes that's what
Adam Schiff is telling us and we've
heard it from others the committee did
find that Trump made false statements
about the results of the 2020 election
insofar as he claimed that he won even
though he lost
and then he used those false statements
to encourage his followers to challenge
the results
in so doing he encouraged the violent
attack on the U.S Capitol on January 6
2021 which about a million of us on our
stream watched live on that day
the evidence against Trump includes his
own words which the committee has looked
at extensively the actions of those who
participated in the attacks and their
claims that they were there because
Trump told him to go
Trump made repeated claims that the
election was stolen from him he made
false claims that it was stolen in
particular ways none of which were found
to be uh have any Merit he urged his
supporters to quote never give up to
never concede to fight like hell to
March to the capital to show support for
him in addition to Trump's public words
we have evidence of the planning and the
coordination and the behind the scenes
of this plan that was drafted up for
Trump
four mic pens to again at this point we
don't even really understand what he was
supposed to do quote send it back to the
states or recognize alternate electors
all things that he couldn't do but there
was planning there was legal work that
went into that and we have other
individuals that were involved who were
caught on video discussing the plan
discussing how to disrupt the election
results and some were even seeing
wearing tactical gear and and some of
them even had weapons so this was all a
major plan
if Donald Trump were to be charged in
connection with the attack
from what happened on January 6th the
possible consequences could include
fines imprisonment or both and we'll
talk about the prison piece a little
later Glenn kirschner had an interesting
comment about that's all hypothetical
but what would the specific charges be
Trump could face potentially
incitement to Riot
conspiracy obstruction of justice among
other crimes each carries its own
potential penalties and the penalties
depend on the severity of the offense
and other factors including what he
would ultimately be convicted of in this
completely hypothetical scenario we're
talking about now of course just because
you're charged doesn't mean you're going
to be found guilty in the interview with
Adam Schiff Jake Tapper asks a good
question which is okay you might have
the evidence for an indictment but you
have the evidence for a conviction those
are two dramatically different questions
and at the end of the the entire thing
is a question I've asked before
can you find a jury in the United States
that will fairly adjudicate Donald Trump
and what I mean by that is is there
really anyone in the U.S who would say
I am open-minded enough about Trump
that whatever preconceived notions I
have about him and what he did I will
rule based only on the evidence
presented in this trial I don't know
that I could do that I don't know that I
could do that because it would be very
difficult for me to completely put aside
everything that over the last five years
and in the couple of years since the
riots uh in the year plus since the riot
almost two years since the riots I have
learned about Donald Trump so so there
is a real question can Trump get an
actual Fair jury trial in the U.S
that'll be a conversation we have a
little bit later
Stephen Bannon had an epic meltdown over
Trump's nft Trading Card grift you have
to see this video there are elements in
Maga world that are Furious about this
nft launch last week Trump teasing I'm
going to be making a major announcement
tomorrow
and the announcement was that you could
buy digital trading cards of scrumps in
various outfits looking like a superhero
they should have had Trump on the toilet
at 3am posting to truth social essential
or Trump on The View saying if Ivanka
weren't my daughter I would like to date
her those would be the interesting Trump
trading cards instead they were like
Trump in a Spider-Man outfit okay anyway
Steve Bannon can't believe it Steve
Bannon melts down and says what on who
came up with this disastrous idea now
they're called Trump digital trading
cards okay these cards feature some of
the I can't do this anymore
he's one of the greatest Presidents in
history but I got to tell you that's not
true whoever what business partner and
anybody in the comms team in anybody
marlago I love the folks down there but
we're War they ought to be fired today
right you came out with something that's
so important which I still don't think
gets to the heart of it and hey you
don't have three harder cores than
Cortez Bannon and sub goregons right
there and we're getting blown up we're
the biggest supporters and this is
stupid they understand walk me through
it walk me through your assessment of
this sir yeah
never should have happened
I I mean look it's fun it's hyperbolic
but whoever wrote that that pitch should
be fired and should never be involved in
any I don't want them making Trump
should be fired and never be involved in
politics ever again the the presidential
napkins for Mar-A-Lago okay anybody who
came up with that and the president's
War chest is is pretty strong right now
yes because he claimed he was raising
money for 2022 candidates and he kept 80
of it we've got two years until the
actual you know inauguration we don't
have time to waste if you want to do
this kind of stuff you know have have a
peon do it okay get get somebody who's
recognized in the Maga world to you know
put their face to this thing and do it
yeah like Seb Gorka or Steve Bannon
right but the President should not be
involved with this when we yeah so this
was you know Mega world was pretty split
over the stupid digital trading cards
some of them maybe they really like
liked it but at least they went along
with it and said this is amazing but
Bannon and Gorka couldn't do it now the
there's a lot of money laundering
questions around it the idea would be
that you could launder money through
these nft trading cards someone could
potentially buy a whole bunch of these
digital trading cards using illicit
funds or funds that they would like to
really be contributing to Trump's
campaign but they're in excess of the
legal limits for those contributions
they could buy a bunch of those cards
and that would be a way to funnel uh
money to Donald Trump you could also
launder money personally by buying a
bunch of these cards with illicit funds
then at a later date selling them and
then it potentially might be a way to
clean that money for the individual
couple different ways that you could
actually use this to launder but
absolutely pathetic and humiliating uh
uh decision which financially may have
actually worked out because they're
claiming that the trading cards sold out
I I know it's just all completely
Bonkers but they're claiming that they
the grift worked that they got 99 out of
enough people
Maga people and I'm not going to redo it
but remember
cult members are overwhelmingly likely
to continue falling for the stuff the
cult leader says people who get scammed
are overwhelmingly likely to be scammed
again and again and again we've spoken
about why extensively uh won't redo that
here but it seems to be happening make
sure you're following the David Pacman
show on Instagram at davidpackman show
if you would like to see an incredible
heartwarming picture
of me with my daughter taking in the
Argentinian Men's National Team World
Cup win yesterday
check out my personal Instagram at
david.pakman it is uh it is a picture
that will bring a tear to your eye her
first World Cup and we got the win it's
incredible we'll take a quick break I
know many of you have said David sir
you've got to cover America Fest oh
believe me we're going to get to America
Fest after the break
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right let's start with America Fest
2022 and Carrie Lakes disgusting rant
which should really serve as a very
scary warning to what is potentially to
come if these people figure out a way to
get more power now fortunately Kerry
Lake lost her Arizona gubernatorial
election and by lost I mean her opponent
Katie Hobbs received more votes and thus
Katie Hobbs will be Governor rather than
Kerry Lake some people seem to think
that's crazy but to me it's logical
Katie Hobbs got more votes so Katie
Hobbs is the governor coming in rather
than Kerry Lake Kerry Lake lost so she
doesn't get to be the governor this is a
complicated concept for many of these
right Wingers this rant and by the way I
don't think this carry Lake stuff Carey
lake is still even though she lost she
ran one election and she lost she's
still being held up as a hero she got
one of the Prime speaking times at this
America Fest event over the weekend but
I think
obviously she's not going to become the
governor so they're going to stop
interviewing at some point I think
she'll maybe end up on Fox news or
something like that
she
I I don't even know where to start she
makes an obscene gesture to the media
for being mean to Trump
and one of the funny things is she makes
the gesture to the back of the room
I'm pretty sure it was only right-wing
media covering this thing take a look at
this anybody I know and these Bastards
of the media want to drag him through
the mud
okay
and she's making an obscene gesture
right now
and the crowd is cheering
yeah she's pointing to the back of the
room
um this is part of the kind of low base
politics that we've covered the American
writing increasingly sliding towards
while we on the left want to talk about
hey you know what dental insurance
should be included in health insurance
why is it separate or is there a way we
can figure out to uh make a transition
off of fossil fuels for home heating
more affordable for everybody these are
the types of questions we're concerned
with this is the stuff that the right is
doing which is increasingly just being
titillating by swearing or making
obscene gestures or making fun of groups
of people usually minority groups of
people that are disadvantaged or
certainly not in positions of power
speaking of which also now very popular
to do sort of a little light anti-trans
rhetoric No Matter What by stating your
pronouns but then saying something
stupid like Carrie Lake says my pronouns
are I won
I know that right now we can identify as
anything we want but I want you to know
I identify as a proud election denying
deplorable
are you with me
yeah
and my pronouns
are
foreign
I just saw another red light go off by
the way
and my pronouns are I one
she lost her opponent got more votes
that's why she's speaking at America
Fest rather than preparing to be the
governor of Arizona so why is this
getting so popular this anti-trans stuff
making fun of pronouns why is it
becoming so popular among Mega trumpists
one reason is that Trump has shown a
tendency to be sort of hostile to trans
rights he's made statements and taken
actions that are obviously hostile to
the trans Community where he ridicules
weight lifters and swimmers and does his
whole routine and talks about teaching
transgender so the suck ups are going to
follow Trump's lead that's one reason
why this is going on secondly
um Trump supporters have been emboldened
to express similar views and to adopt
the same sentiment it's kind of like the
Kanye anti-Semitism thing which we
talked about at the top of the show it
has an impact and they're feeling
emboldened and more comfortable publicly
saying they believe this stuff there's
also probably a belief to some degree
that if you are aligned with trumpism on
the anti-trans stuff
you're Mo you will be able to mobilize
your base in other ways and
unfortunately it seems to be true to
some degree we saw the anti-trans and
homophobic stuff very very strongly
front and center at CPAC and it did seem
to coalesce and excite people and it
seems like that's more or less what
continues to go on so to the extent that
they seem to get a reaction by doing
this they'll continue the pronoun stuff
even if they don't actually understand a
damn thing about what's going on in the
world of trans and gender as they
clearly don't
um Kerry Lake also focusing her ire on
Dr fauci and calling him an elf we're
not going to answer to that evil elf Dr
fauci anymore wow
are you really powerful to speak out
against a retiring 80-something-year-old
Doctor Who spent 50 years helping people
how strong she is
[Applause]
let's lock that man up fast
[Applause]
fast lock him up we don't need a big
cell for that guy
small one will do
are they also making fun of fauci
because he's short like I mean we're
getting
America Fest making fun of gay people
trans people
and short people I guess I mean it's all
very very strange and then uh one more
of these clips from Kerry Lake uh
talking about burning Maricopa to the
ground I guess over the election results
that she doesn't like because she lost
they are
right
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do they
have built a house of cards here in
Maricopa County
[Applause]
whoops
I think they're all wondering what I'm
gonna do yeah you're gonna do nothing
Carrie you lost
I'll tell you what I'm Not Just Gonna
Knock that house of cards over
we're gonna Burn It to the Ground
unclear if she's threatening criminality
there but this is at least for now
someone who's considered exciting
a great speaker a great motivator of
whatever Mega trumpism is and she's very
very dangerous now before we move on to
other America Fest stuff I want to look
at one other Kerry Lake event over the
weekend Kerry Lake spoke at a log cabin
republican event and she said she
prefers gay men to straight men yeah
it's all bizarre it's all very very
strange a Log Cabin Republicans is a
group of gay Republicans it's we've
talked about them before
um here is Carrie Lake speaking there
and she's going to explain to us why she
prefers gay men
very strange
so one of the things that I think some
of you how many of you
are in some ways
[Music]
you're 80 30 100 of the men in Media
okay and so all of my friends did you
guys know that 80 90 100 of the men in
Media
are gay that I did not know that I have
to admit
amazing fun Sparks Savvy people in the
world Amen and the one thing I really
was gonna miss when I walked away from
the media
was my gay friends right
right turns out I get into politics and
I had no idea of concerned about
politics was called what came down as
well
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'll tell you what I like them
better because they know how to think
right exactly
the gay men
who are I guess on the right know how to
think right whereas the straight men
don't so this is pretty wacky but it's
an opportunity to just kind of revisit
why are there Log Cabin Republicans in
the sense that the Republican party has
been varying from
implicitly to completely overtly and
violently hostile to the LGBT community
why would there be gay Republicans and
of course the answers are not unique to
gay folks sometimes it's political
values right you could have gay
Republicans that support the Republican
Party
because they really align with the party
on other values limited government when
that's what the Republican Party stood
for it doesn't under Maga individual
Freedom when it was what the party stood
for it doesn't under Maga being strong
on National Defense Trump didn't
understand anything about National
Defense so it could just be that they
say well I'm in a disagreement with the
party on LGBT issues but I'm really in
agreement on these other things and
that's more important and then you get
some Log Cabin Republicans personal
beliefs you could have gay Republicans
that support the party because they
actually believe in the principles that
the party represents aside from LGBT and
uh there are also I mean I I hate to
bring up Milo yiannopoulos but Milo
yiannopoulos who used to be gay now he
says he's not it's very complicated when
he was gay he said I'm still a
republican because being gay is bad I'm
gay but I wish I wasn't is sort of what
Milo used to say and it would be better
not to be so I'm still a republican it
was kind of weird and then strategic
voting to some degree I mean if you're a
wealthy gay Republican and you find the
Republican position on LGBT issues
disgusting but you're going to save a
boatload on taxes under Republicans you
might just say I'm still going to vote
for republicans and I just disagree
about this other stuff but it's saving
me a whole bunch of money so that that's
another possibility Kerry Lake really
strange I guess she likes gay men better
than straight men and she also had one
other really wacky thing she said at
this event
Kerry Lake
said while speaking to the Log Cabin
Republicans
that Trump is more amazing than her own
husband have you ever seen someone suck
up to this degree
look at this clip it's starting to be
painful the degree to which Carrie lake
is I think auditioning to be Donald
Trump's vice president
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yep
[Applause]
[Music]
her husband can be thanked later but
really the most amazing man in her life
is Trump why is she doing this is it
career advancement she wants to be
Trump's VP or at least Trump's VP
running mate even if they lose maybe
it'll get her some attention sort of
like Sarah Palin had for a while after
losing as John McCain's VP in 28 2008
maybe is it personal gain like she
thinks it would help her with something
about trying to steal the election in
Arizona which he's trying to do or maybe
it will help her continue to grift money
to say stuff like this my husband is
less amazing than Trump and then of
course fear-based politics might also
apply within the Republican party is
there fear of reprisal which is causing
Kerry Lake to feel pressure and to
continue the uh show in which she just
thanks Trump endlessly for everything
and he's so good and he's so amazing I
don't know what the answer is but it's
starting to get pretty cringy and pretty
painful to see but it doesn't look like
it's going to stop anytime soon and any
opportunity she gets she will pray at
the altar she's on her knees for Trump
Jesus I think is the way we would put it
after the break we'll get to other
elements of America Fest we're going to
hear a new analysis from Glenn kirschner
and so many other things glad you're
with us Friday December 23 this Friday
you're in membership special
your first month's payment will be
donated to charity that helps people
directly with cash and doubled matched
dollar for dollar make sure you're on my
mailing list for this Friday sign up at
davidpackman.com
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show legal
expert Glenn kirschner says that failed
former president Donald Trump is
potentially facing 25 years in prison
based on the potential criminal
referrals that he is up against we are
going to listen to him explain it
himself there's a good Newsweek write up
about it Trump May face 25 years in
prison and be blocked from future office
let's listen this is Glenn kirschner on
the joy read program on MSNBC
uh remember nobody here is saying Trump
is going to prison we're talking about
based on the crimes Trump may be charged
with what would the potential sentence
be a referral doesn't mean they're
Prosecuting they don't have the power to
do that but would such a referral at
least have sort of value even if they
can't get get it all the way to closer
it will have value you know the
Department of Justice Prides itself on
exercising independent prosecutorial
discretion but they can't turn a blind
eye to a co-equal branch of government
that has done such an exhaustive
investigation when they pass all of that
evidence over to doj and they recommend
criminal investigations and prosecutions
and here's the thing it's great that
they're talking about obstructing
official proceedings that's a 20-year
offense it's great that they're talking
about conspiracy to commit offenses
against the United States that's a
five-year offense but the important one
Joy is the one you mentioned
Insurrection why because the available
sentence if you're convicted of
insurrection unlike those other charges
is that you shall be prohibited from
holding office under the United States
that quite frankly is the one I'm
rooting for and of course it continues
to be
stunning that not only can Trump run for
president he he is running for president
even though the campaign so far has been
a complete and total flop now let's be
very real about what I know many of you
consider to be the most important
question here
do presidents get indicted in the United
States could a president get indicted
why has a president never been indicted
in the United States let's start the
conversation with a reminder that no
president has ever done the things
Donald Trump did put that aside for now
because we want to talk now about
historical precedent to put it in one
word
tradition is the reason that presidents
have not historically been indicted by
the Department of Justice and what I
mean by that is
historically out of the principle of
executive immunity which holds the
president is not subject to criminal
prosecution while serving in office
the doj has not pursued charges against
a precedent and the principle behind
that is if you charge a sitting
president
you inhibit their ability to do the job
of being president of the United States
and if a president worries that what
they do might get them indicted while
they are President they might act other
than how they believe is in the best
interest of the country for fear of a
personal prosecution or because of the
distraction of a criminal trial however
after leaving office there is nothing
that would prevent or preclude a
president from being investigated from
being potentially charged with crimes
and from being prosecuted importantly
you also have impeachment impeachment
for high crimes and misdemeanors is a
completely separate process from
Criminal prosecution and doesn't require
any crime to have been committed
important to understand that the January
6 committee investigation and potential
criminal referrals would not be for
impeachable offenses because the house
could handle that itself trumps out of
office he's already been impeached twice
this is about in their investigative
carrying out of their investigative role
the house may come across what are
apparent crimes and refer those to the
Department of Justice tradition is the
only reason
why historically you have not seen
prosecution of a president Trump is now
out of office we may know within hours
whether the house committee says Trump's
on the list of people who committed
crimes here's a criminal referral we may
know within hours or a day or two and
then the question will be what does the
doj do under Merit Garland Merit Garland
has said things like Trump running for
president wouldn't get him out of jail
what's going to get out of jail free
card fine but he has not expressed that
his doj actually has the testicular
fortitude for lack of a better term to
really charge Trump so we will see and
we will find out very very soon I told
you earlier in the show that America
Fest held an event over the weekend and
it was horrible and dystopian and we are
going to look at a few clips and really
it reminds me these people are dangerous
but they also are way better than the
left at organizing these sort of pump up
events I'm going to start with a clip of
Donald Trump Jr coming out and I know
that it's going to be you know it's
funny it's cartoonish it's like a
wrestling intro it's also a little loud
just as a head up if you're listening in
headphones but I'm turning it down for
us but make fun of this at your own
Peril because this type of stuff works
here's Donald J Trump Jr coming out
[Applause]
[Music]
there's also pyrotechnics if you're only
listening
[Music]
hello
yeah I mean listen I'm with you that it
is hard not to laugh because it's so
absurd but I've spoken so many times
before the right knows how to throw
these events coalesce people they do
multiple C packs Turning Point USA does
events they've got America Fest as one
of them they've got the Turning Point
Summit all these different things
this stuff actually does get people
engaged and part of the reason that the
youngest voting group 18 to whatever
isn't even more left skewed is that the
right does a way better job of
activating and getting people together
and the pyrotechnics and the music and
the entire thing the left doesn't have
it the closest thing we had at one point
was net net Roots nation which I used to
go to but no longer do it's very milk
toast it's very mediocre a lot of
infighting a lot of like uh you know all
the people that actually have success
that should be leading sessions we have
political disagreements with them so
we're gonna have like it it's it's a
mess it's a mess the right is actually
better at this So eventually Don Jr
spoke and again he continues to be
obsessed like many of these people
obsessed with gender today pushing for
three-year-old children to be
indoctrinated by their purple hair
teachers
to go through changing permanent sexual
reassignment surgeries and if parents
and by the way the little skips these
are in the source videos I unfortunately
can't do anything about them parents
want to get involved their domestic
terrorists oh
if parents want to maybe be a part of
that conversation let's be clear that
kid can't buy a pack of cigarettes for
another 15 years
it can't vote although hunt them too
because of course they don't know what
they're talking about
for another 15 years but they can and we
don't know what Junior is talking about
either and I may not know for another 15
years they decide to mutilate their
bodies permanently
to satisfy
some insane woke teacher satisfy what is
the deal with that okay
um obsessed obsessed with gender
obsessed with imaginary things that
aren't actually happening and the gender
Obsession continued Republican senator
Josh Hawley a sort of
pseudo-insurrectionist that was the way
I would refer to him he came out and he
said here's an idea boys turn off the
porn and go talk to a real woman you can
give yourself two and pour yourself out
to young men
pour yourself out into a woman let me
get
me right how about it
young man why don't you
America Fest quickly turning into like a
pickup artist type conference instead of
of right-wing political conference I
guess with this pseudo in cell group
it's the same thing but yeah don't wait
for her you go ask show her a little
respect
and then you take her out and you treat
her right how about that
don't make her cater to your whims right
treat her right
Treat Her Right treat her like see what
she is isn't this like a weird thing for
a political event a woman
a person of incredible significance
created in the image of God and you know
what you treat her right and then one
day you do her the honor and show her
the respect of asking her to marry you
yeah and then you go get married
uh dating advice with Josh Hawley
America Fest taking a very weird turn
there were like in-cell Vibes around the
entire thing then out came Dennis Prager
and he said sex is terrific okay thanks
Dennis the greatest need in life after
food and shelter is meaning it is even
when sex and sex is terrific just for
the record right and there were good
blacks and bad blacks did you guys know
that there are good blacks and bad
blacks there are even bad lesbians there
are good women and bad women there are
good men and bad men there are good
whites and bad whites we don't give a
damn about whether you're white
we don't give a damn whether you're
black
just like you want you you brush away
your bad breath and you shower away your
bad odor you should brush away your bad
mood you owe it to everyone in your life
men can be lesbians are you out of your
minds yes they are we are living in the
age of chaos and you know the greatest
all right so there's Dennis Prager very
very messed up video
um it's it's just weird because so much
of the stuff they talk about is
meaningless like it helps no one achieve
anything or solve any problem it's
totally disconnected from The Real World
and then a guy named Benny Johnson got a
standing ovation for yelling fauci for
prison this is the this is the level of
what they have going on solving the real
problems of the world as you can see oh
Dr fauci's resigning
how you like that
this is what my boy had to say about Dr
fauci just in time for Christmas
sick of seeing him I know he says he's
gonna retire someone needs to grab that
little elf and Chuck him across
[Applause]
who wants to see that elephant
ladies and gentlemen my pronouns are
prosecuted
come on
oh
my goodness
um that's America Fest so if you were
hoping to learn what is their
legislative agenda for these two years
that they will be controlling the house
you didn't get it if you were hoping to
figure out what is the moral framework
within which they believe government
should I can't even say it seriously you
go government should operate you didn't
get that you got fire fouchy jail fouchy
prosecute fauci fauci retire and you got
my pronouns are i1 and my pronouns are
prosecute fauci that's basically America
Fest that's what we got but these events
bring people together they do them for a
reason they do them for a reason and the
left should figure it out we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P here's my favorite thing and
honestly it's not my favorite thing
here's someone who called in with some
kind of a message to me
but the show is just cranked in the
background so you can't hear anything
and I
um
I believe she's commenting about Kanye
but like her her voice is quieter than
the show
we've never done something like this
before person
okay I I can't do it what's funny is I
hear myself explaining the big the
fundraiser so unfortunately she also
called right during my fundraising pitch
which is crazy so let me just mention it
one more time Friday December 23rd
that's this Friday
we're doing our last membership special
of the year you can get a discounted
membership you'll get the bonus show
you'll get the commercial free audio
feed all of it oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yeah everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad but here's the kicker in addition
to you getting a discounted membership
everyone who signs up Friday with the
coupon code is going to see their first
membership payment donated by us out to
an organization that gives cash to
people who need it
and it's going to be doubled your
contribution will be doubled so if you
get a six dollar a month membership the
six dollars gets donated and then it is
matched up to 12 up to the first fifteen
thousand dollars all you need to do for
now is get on my mailing list you can
sign up at davidpackman.com
Friday you'll get an email telling you
what to do
it's gonna be great I hope it's really
successful on today's bonus show
speaking of the bonus show Argentina
have won the World Cup for the first
time in 36 years I wore my jersey today
yes this will be the last round for the
Jersey until the next World Cup
everybody relax we will talk about it uh
we will talk about the insanity also of
the World Cup in Qatar uh and we'll talk
about the next World Cup we will also
talk about an Ohio teacher who told the
principal that using the preferred
pronouns of students violates her
religion oh God this is happening now
and lastly guns confiscated at U.S
airports have hit record levels and it's
not only Madison cawthorne getting
caught it's other people as well all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com get
instant access we will see you then
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors Ginger armor is
the daily moisturizing mineral sunscreen
perfect for any skin type chemical
sunscreens can cause health issues
including skin irritation and stinging
eyes but with ginger armors ingredients
from plants and minerals and it being
scent free and rubbing on invisibly in
seconds it's the best get 15 off with
code Pacman using the link below